now we have melody time which is so
similar to make my music that actually
I'm sir wondering why they didn't just
call it make my music too I mean it's
almost identical different variations of
songs most of the modern song by modern
singers a little bit poetry thrown in
and even some straightforward stories
it's pretty much the exact same thing
and just like make my music
this one works pretty good too you do
have your straightforward narrative some
of them more forgettable than others but
you also have your selections of
straightforward music and you know
sometimes even straightforward poetry
the poem as lovely as a tree Sigma is
especially nice it's just the Disney
animators drawing what they hear as the
poem is read with a nice soothing music
thrown over it it works pretty well
there's also a really cool section
called bumble boogie which reminds me a
lot of the pink elephant sequence it's
just a bee flying around to a
whacked-out version of flight of the
bumblebee as the music is literally
trying to destroy them it's really
chaotic at least it some fun imagery the
one that probably stands out the most is
the Johnny Appleseed one when I was a
kid I really liked it well it's a
teenager I got a little bit more cynical
and started making fun of it now that
I'm older I actually find myself really
liking it again it's got some real heavy
atmosphere some real heavy visuals and
some of those backgrounds are just
incredible yeah it's still a little
corny and I do make fun of it sometimes
but it still holds up it's the size and
scope that they give something that
seems so relatively simple and yet they
show that took so much dedication that
image of the apple trees becoming the
clouds that's one of the most surreal
things I've ever seen I remember it even
stayed in my mind as a little kid and it
really really is gripping in fact it's
so good it probably could have been its
own movie I'm sorry wondering why they
tucked it away in here
the Lord is good
and so I thank the Lord for giving me
the things I need the Sun and rain and
Anna seus he's been good
funny bit of trivia when I was a little
kid in Catholic school they actually had
this as the prayer we said before craze
isn't that weird and they told us not to
sing it - how is that possible you can't
say these words without singing it it
can't be done we did it anyway and I'm
sure God knew we were thankful for the
grub and then the last segment they end
on his Pecos Bill son through a lot of
folk and country music this is also fun
- and really creative but again why do
they end the film on this I mean it's
funny it's enjoyable and it's catchy but
dude did you see the Apple seen one I
mean that was far superior Pecos Bill
just ends on a guy I don't even know
what note I'm not sure if it's sad I'm
not sure if it's happy it's just kind of
odd like I said I don't have a problem
with it I just don't know why they
closed on it but either way melody time
has some really good shorts in it as
well as some good music and really great
animation the atmosphere is really heavy
in this one again maybe not Fantasia
heavy but there are points where I hits
that traditional Disney charm that only
Disney can have and they recreate it
quite well here
melody time is definitely one to check
out
ah